welcome to this video playing yeah
puh-lease can teammate of mine so let's
do go to some not theoretical opening
don't want to expose all our preparation
together yeah the Kings Indian reversed
Kings Indian attack can i play something
like you know it before a bit hard too
hard to prepare okay let's play your
form it's not the greatest setup ever
for white this is a very flexible set up
that black and can go for I go here
maybe I can play me five let's do this
now as long as I'm able to Bishop f4 to
cover it if he attacks it I need to play
night f1 first so that I have those yeah
this is some a good idea trying to open
up the position yeah I take let's take
it
and see what happens now look f7f night
g 5 year ok and i'm wondering i made
this one intending ig4 and if he plays
v5 i hope that c4 Sammy c4d 495 let's
see it's quite a dynamic way to play
this and this basically translates to i
have no idea what's going on but ok this
is an active way intro me needs to take
now and night before i am okay now which
means exactly but sometimes the german
word slips in there okay what now h4 h4
now if i have stuff like that or d6 like
a kamikaze I've I'm threatening queen
bee three actually I maybe this is into
that if it takes with the Queen I have
the snide g5 idea energy 594 and there's
also queen bee three at some point at
least
uh-huh hey you three that's 2 a 3 and
queen bee three
hmm yeah I hope that this is some
compensation it may be is I'm not sure
it's a nice position for this night good
diagonal I'm not sure needs to be
cautious of coconut play any move so
this one should I play queen bee three
now queen bee three
hmm maybe
okay Wow what about this is this too
risky it looks dangerous for black and
now i can take ya thought ya i don't see
any compensation really maybe some weird
to know there's no discovery can take
you Quinn is hanging to c4 on where
homes you for this be five they are
still be five and I can just take I
think if he goes be five just looking
one on a 93 is the last idea
yeah still okay rookie three it's not
too convincing
I wait I can actually take him and
Quincy three attending rook e8 mate and
I think he needs to play a king moves
now yeah this really doesn't look like
it should be working wait Quinn Quinn
Quinn Quinn takes and Quincy form may be
nuts not meet winning
don't see a direct win strangely enough
check
don't see when the King looks very open
but I really couldn't figure out this
was stupid [ __ ] got a Queen f7 yeah
yeah and okay this is just just a porn
and mail it down on the clock it's a
pretty decent extra pole it's not too
bad
at the time remember him catching up a
bit kingi jewel problem
check
you know I didn't get this one check
check
check don't surprise me I'm warning ya
this should be winning now at least
perform a positional point of view time
is another issue but check yes
everything's predicted yet it doesn't
have any counter play with the king
check check black time yeah difficult
really difficult i was really surprised
that I had nothing substantial and in
this in this strange position where the
king was so wide open here I probably
had something better I mean this looks
like it really should be should be over
quimby five computer wants to go okay
yeah Bishop takes the fibers to compute
a move I thought about this briefly but
it looks so crazy to give up the bishop
it's probably okay here simply because
you're afraid of this battery yeah the
bishop behind the Queen Bishop a 8
Quincy 6 Quincy to mate but black
probably doesn't manage to get this on
the board and I'm I'm quickly a rookie
one rookie 7 Queen B 6 Queen f6 and so
on yeah computer says it's instantly
winning but I couldn't couldn't really
do that ok so I still I was surprised
that there wasn't a direct win here yeah
computer wants to do exactly the same
yeah yeah okay this end cap is is some
quite okay I mean it's important but
still I'm rook endgame some notoriously
Jewish so I should should have something
better before probably just taking on d5
with the bishop thanks for watching